[Music]
rockstar bono says his songs make him
sicker than mono
yeah those youtube songs that you love
to binge make the zillionaire lead
singer cringe which means it's time for
[Music]
bono whose real name is lawrence kudlow
who knew
said he is just so embarrassed by many
of his own songs claiming that he
cringes and turns red when he hears most
of them on the radio well that's how i
feel when i see him dance he made the
comments on the awards chatter podcast
adding that he hates the band's name too
and yet no apology for his giant 1980s
mullet looked like there was a rooster
sitting on his head that mullet was so
bad billy ray cyrus offered him a ride
to supercuts
but all of the embarrassing stories i've
heard
launching a music career that makes you
hundreds of millions of dollars is
hardly the most devastating plus isn't
he kind of insulting me
as a fan is he saying i should be
embarrassed for liking some of those
songs if so good luck i don't get
embarrassed which you probably already
realize if you have been watching this
show
but maybe we're being too hard on bono
and you too let's listen to one of their
biggest all-time hits
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
hit it
that's the edge
go edge go edge
go
edge joey you know i feel like he
betrayed me because i was a fan when no
one knew what they were in 1979 1980 i
was there at larry mullin's 18th
birthday
at the old waldorf and he's basically
saying like we sucked back then well
screw you right joey screw bono and his
all his friends and everything he stands
for
you know i'm so up to date on this music
i was really surprised because i thought
this dude like got taken out by a tree
on a ski slope a few years ago
and uh
so i had to i had to read it twice uh
you know their music does suck i'm sorry
greg but uh with the fact we put them on
the shelf with queen or even the eagles
just blows my mind
their music is google's listen we've had
an american we've had an american
version of you two it was creed and even
scott stapp knew that the shelf life
right you are
all over one of the greatest fans
you two had a series of albums from like
i'd say 1980 to 84 which were
amazing and even with bono's
high-pitched voice it was still moving
chris it was moving ignore everything
this guy no he's right he's right he's
right and by the way by the way this
like this obnoxiousness only like makes
me think i am so glad i was never a fan
though it happened to me in my own
fandom rem did this yeah rem did this
yes they're like we're never going to
play shiny happy people yeah so we're so
embarrassed by that song and i'm like
really yeah michael scott be embarrassed
about the fact that you look like alan
ginsberg after starving yourself right
like i mean come on like but that's a
thing you make it to a certain point and
then they're like too cool for their
like they're disowning their previous
selves yes absolutely me yes i oh god
that just gets you know what it you know
it's also cat it's easy to say you suck
after you've made a trillion dollars but
then you just throw your fans under the
bus for supporting you and making you
rich yeah you have to be grateful yes
you like you know
maybe it's so embarrassing but now you
have hundreds of millions of dollars
like i do that though with my
embarrassing moments but like not on
that level right like i'm you know at
least i didn't get arrested you know
like
that photo hasn't made it on the
internet yet like you know like they
gotta be grateful it could be worse than
being super super rich i never got paid
for any of that stuff yeah exactly you
should have kt you followed the band
around in a yeah for uh years uh you
were uh you were you you they knew you
you knew them uh are you feel like
you've been broken
i'm just afraid she's gonna come over
and stop me
where are we going with them
um what do you make of this
i was actually teaching nuclear weapons
at mit when they were a big deal that's
just funny
no the thing that i just cannot believe
you know is that the far left what are
they doing they virtue signal everybody
about everything he has run out there's
nobody else to virtue signal so he has
to virtue signal himself oh that's a
very interesting point that's a very now
i don't think he's far left because i
hear like i will like he was very he's
very pro-capitalist as far as if i can
remember correctly but you're right it's
like when you run out of people to slam
you end up having to slam yourself but i
don't think that you know what it is
it's the it's it's the over to
over-the-top self-deprecation that is
like a subtle humble brag right right
it's like i'm so awesome
that i can endure my own slings and
arrows right i do that it's like when i
make fun of mine i do that yeah you know
what so apologize to bono yeah i didn't
know
all right i don't hate him i don't know
him it's a passive-aggressive thing he
expects you to say oh no no no yeah oh i
also genuinely do hate myself too to be
clear oh geez stop hating you know stop
the hate cat
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else